Now, that's that.
>> [clears throat]
>> Coming back to the issue.
Tragic news today.
Lord, keep our numbers steady for your
glory.
San Diego
mosque
Two teenagers went in.
Three
individuals. And then from what I saw,
the latest reports
Yep, 2 Corinthians 12:7-10. That's the
thorn in my side, brother. Huck boxing.
That's what I have in mind. I saw the
reports, the two teenagers
But from what I gathered
So,
here's where
being
a true son, daughter of God, and a true
servant, slave of the Lord Jesus Christ
>> [clears throat]
>> matters and comes in.
You see Muslims, Jesus sees human beings
that he created in his image, for his
glory to save them.
But you got some sick people, wicked
people, demonic people
who will
rejoice in the one
if they belong to the other, meaning the
other tribe.
And you have people who are so full
of hate towards Islam
Right? They talk about anti-Semitism
and hating Jews, but then they turn a
blind eye to the hatred of non-combatant
Muslims elderly or children
who have been
to smithereens in the name of
counter-terrorism
Right?
That do not care if Muslims get
Yeah, it's all over the news, brother.
Here you go. It happened today in San
Diego.
So, here is when you're going to know do
you love the Lord Jesus Christ more than
your tribe? Then your
cult, then your
fears and hatred?
Do you?
Well, then that means you cannot
rejoice, you cannot celebrate
what happened.
Whether
a Jewish person
or a Muslim person gets
gets
Your heart should break because if you
believe the Bible, these are human
creatures created for Christ to know
Jesus and enjoy him.
If that's your position. I'm not trying
to be politically correct and I'm trying
to let you know this is what happens
when we lose our perspective and let our
hate for the other
consume us
that we do not care what happens to the
other. But brethren,
there are among us Muslims who became
Christian.
At one time in their life they were the
other. They were Muslims.
You didn't see what God saw. Now they
love the Lord Jesus Christ and are
saved.
Now, can you imagine hating them back
then and rejoicing in their death?
Only to see them come to the Lord Jesus
Christ later?
Perspective right here.
San Diego
mosque
shooting
today. It's all over the news.
Breaking news.
Right here.
Three Muslim
The two people there were teenagers and
from the last report because it's
breaking
they
self-inflicted gun wounds.
Five all together.
So, again, may God constrain me not to
slander,
right? God save me from defaming,
slandering, and destroying righteous
anger.
But, can I ask you a question and be
very honest with yourselves in the Lord?
What do you think
will happen and what kind of environment
do you think you'll create
when you're constantly doing spiritual
Yossi blood baths, constantly demonizing
the other, constantly
>> [clears throat]
>> vilifying the other?
What do you think is going to happen to
the people who look up to you?
What do you think it's going to do to
their hearts and minds?
Will you even care about being Jesus to
them?
Destroy their arguments, win them to
Christ. I'm not saying
Listen to me. I'm not saying the dogs
among all these groups. The filthy,
lying dogs, blasphemers, who are full of
Satan and hate and venom, who want to
see you killed, treat them like dogs,
crush them without mercy.
But, is everyone like that?
Do you think everyone's like that?
Okay, let me remind you.
Okay, let me remind you. I'm going to
give you two examples.
I'm going to give you two examples.
Okay, I need you to listen to this. It's
why I titled it mastering.
All right?
Let me tell you
I am the result
and the fruit
of a nasty, rabid, arrogant Muslim
da'ee.
Let me remind you of my story.
In the '90s, when I was coming back to
the faith, to the Lord Jesus Christ,
a Muslim da'ee met me
and humiliated me, insulted me,
belittled me, and showed me no love,
creating a fire in my heart, crying out
to Jesus that Christ give me answers,
and I'll never allow any Christian to
ever be humiliated by a Muslim again,
and putting me on a path to destroy
Islam.
What do you think would have happened if
I met a gentle Muslim?
A friendly Muslim
who asked questions but wasn't nasty and
arrogant to me?
Now, let me give you the story of Ahmed
Deedat. You ready?
Can I give you the story of Ahmed
Deedat?
Are you listening?
Ahmed Deedat,
his story, go listen to his story.
He used to work
some menial job.
I need you to listen to this.
I hope proud as a believer can constrain
himself unless he knows what I'm not
because this guy's like out there. I
love you, bro. Take it easy, man.
Ahmed Deedat,
tell God logic to come here and learn a
thing or two.
See?
See this guy here?
I don't know what to do with this guy. I
love this guy. We go way back, but
he just likes to just shoot. He just
shoots anywhere, sprays, hopes at least
one bullet hits.
Ahmed Deedat, let me tell you the story
of Ahmed Deedat.
He used to work a menial job.
And according to his testimony in South
Africa, where he was working, there was
a Christian missionary school nearby,
and the Christian missionaries would
come and ask him questions, and bully
him, belittle him, and harass him.
And they made him look stupid.
According to his testimony, according to
his testimony,
as he was working
his menial job, I don't remember what it
was exactly. I don't know if it was
construction, painting, but you'll find
it. It's been a while.
As he was going through
the storefront that he was working in,
he found
a book by an Indian
Well, it was a Muslim scholar in India.
I don't believe he was Indian.
This Muslim scholar was debating
Christian missionaries cuz now, remember
in the
19th century, 1800s and turn of the 19th
20th century, 1800s and 1900s, remember
because of British colonialism,
British colonialism when Brit- Britain
had its tentacles all over the world and
had a presence in India,
a whole swarm of Christian missionaries
went to India debating Muslims trying to
convert them. But, listen to the story
and I'll find you I believe the author
of the book was actually an Arab Muslim
scholar living in India. But, we'll
we'll fact-check.
One of the most celebrated Christian
missionaries is a man named C. G.
Pfander.
C. G. Pfander. A missionary to Muslims
who was in India trying to convert
Muslims, wrote books that are classics
till this day. In point of fact,
J. Smith was influenced by Pfander.
That's why his ministry, his YouTube
channel is called Pfander, after this
great Christian missionary.
Do you guys know this?
Here.
Pfander Films, the name Pfander is named
after that Christian missionary named C.
G. Pfander.
Christian missionary wrote books,
debated Muslims.
He wrote a book called Mizanul Haq.
The balance of truth. A Christian
response to Muslim objections. Now, pray
the websites remain for many years until
the Lord returns. All of these books
that are over 100 years old are online
for free.
On answeringislam.info. Let me show you
the book.
So, when you go to individual authors,
let's look at individual authors, you're
going to see here classic
library of classical books.
Cuz the copyright has expired, these
books are online for free. Let me give
you a little history.
All right.
Right here.
C.
G. Pfander, Carl Gottlieb Pfander.
Here, Mizanul Haq, the book.
You're learning about history?
So, let me get you the link
to the website. Download them before the
sites are gone. They're gone, they're
gone, brethren.
Here's the main page. This is the site I
wrote for until the late what, 2017, I
believe.
And then the owner stopped updating the
website.
Yeah, we know, brother.
We know he's silent. Take it easy.
Today, Protestant believer. We're not
talking about about attacking. I love
you, brothers. Tomorrow, when I do
something calling out Zakir Naik, come
and then gun hole cuz I'm trying to talk
about the Muslims I got San Diego,
brother. Please, Lord.
Rain us in.
Make our love for Christ greater than
our hate for Islam. I love him. He Kenny
Rogers. What, I don't know what to do
sometimes. Stuck with Allah. Stuck with
Allah.
So, then you go there. You got the link.
Go right here.
C. G. Pfander.
Mizanul Haq.
Now, there was a Muslim
a Muslim in India that challenged him to
a debate, debated him, and wrote a
response to this book called Izharul
Haq.
Right? Izharul
Izharul Haq
Here it is.
And here it is, Izharul Haq, the book.
Here you go.
And the author
Maulana M. Rahmatullah Kairavi
Dedeat found this book.
All right.
Izharul Haq
This is it.
When Dedeat found this book, he ate it
up.
By reading this book, Dedeat became
emboldened, went after Christian
Christians, and started destroying them.
Now, what's my point? Let me explain.
Do you think if a Christian came to
Dedeat and was a little nicer
and critiquing Islam and explaining the
gospel of Jesus Christ?
Do you think that maybe
that would have made Dedeat less harsh,
less mean, less wicked, less hateful,
less blasphemous?
Right?
So, Dedeat
came out with
a vengeance.
All this time you Christian missionaries
used to mock my faith.
I didn't know nothing about Islam, used
to bully me.
Now, I'm going to turn the tables. I'm
going to treat you the way you treated
me.
That's my story.
Because of that Muslim Dawah was a
follower of Dedeat.
When he disrespected me and humiliated
me, he put
a passion in my heart to annihilate,
obliterate Muslim apologists, show them
no mercy, and protect Christians.
See, that's what happened to me.
Do you understand when I came into
Muslim apologetics, you know what my
prayer was? Lord,
give me answers so I never allow any
Christian to be humiliated by any Muslim
ever again. Notice what I prayed, and
God answered that prayer. I didn't say,
"Lord, give me answers so I can see
Muslims get saved."
My attitude was, I will never allow any
Muslim to humiliate Christians ever
again.
That's why over 90% of my material is
related to the defense of Christianity
and destroying the objections against
Christianity.
So, that was a blessing what he did, but
it left me
in such a way where I dis- despise
Islamic apologetics,
I despise Muslim apologists, and I don't
have respect for them.
See how things change? What's my point
in all of this?
>> [clears throat]
>> You have to guard your heart.
You have to ask God to save you and heal
you
from having such a hatred for the other
and such
anger towards another group
that it drowns you from realizing your
purpose is destroy objections, silence
blasphemers, but still your purpose is
to see them get saved and fall in love
with Jesus Christ.
You understand?
That's your purpose.